mid-segment is basically connecting the
midpoints of two sides of a triangle so
for example if this length and this
length are the same that makes this the
midpoint if this segment and this
segment are the same that makes this the
midpoint and if we connect those with a
line segment this is called the mid
segment and the interesting properties
of the mid segment are that it's going
to be parallel to this third side okay
to the base and it's going to be half
the length okay so if this was 10 this
would be 5 okay so that's the idea so
it's parallel and it's gonna be half the
length now if you find the midpoint of
this side right here okay such that
these are the same and you connect these
two midpoints this would be a mid
segment and it's going to be parallel to
this base and half as long and then same
thing here if you connect these two
midpoints this is a mid segment it's
going to be half of this base in
parallel now another interesting
property that sometimes students
overlook is that you know because this
length is half of the base this segment
this segment and this segment are all
going to be the same length okay same
thing over here if these are the same
okay this mid segment is going to be the
same and then these two are the same
these three are going to be the same
okay so here with me so far
I'll also get a couple examples and
we'll understand this little bit better
so here we've got a mid segment you can
see that the these are the two midpoints
are connected there so if this is salmon
that means that the bit of this base
must be double it must be 14 right okay
example number two a little bit
different we're combining algebra with
geometry here here they're giving us
this mid segment okay so let's make sure
that we just have that identified as the
two midpoints so how do we relate this
quantity in this quantity well we know
that the mid segment is half the base so
if we want to make an equation an easy
way to do this is to double the mid
segment and then set it equal to the
base so if we double X plus four then it
will be equal to the base which is 3x
minus six so let's just distribute we
get 2x plus eight equals 3x minus six
let's see you subtract 2x from both
sides so that gives us X minus six
equals eight and we're going to add six
to both sides
okay so that gives us x equals 14 and we
got it so that's the idea if you double
the mid segment then they're gonna be
the same length and you can
equal to the base so I hope this helped
you to understand how to work with the
mid-segment theorem better subscribe to
the channel check out more math tutoring
videos on Mario's math tutor in YouTube
channel and I look forward to helping
you in the future videos I'll talk to
you soon